Hallo ihr Hungrigen!
Wir machen heute lecker Mittagessen und zwar habe ich mir überlegt:
Es gibt heute eine cremige Hähnchenpfanne, die man gut abwandeln kann je nachdem, was für Gemüse man noch da hat.
Das ist einfach nur so ein Basic und ich zeige euch, was ich heute zum Mittag koche.
Dazu gibt's Reis aber dafür gibt's ein extra Video. Das verlinke ich euch dann hier unten in die Videobeschreibung
genauso wie alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
Hamza ich würd' sagen wir legen direkt los, oder?
(H: Yep, sofort!)
Sofort! Also ich hab' jetzt hier meine beschichtete Pfanne
und da gebe ich jetzt erstmal neutrales Öl rein. Ich hab' jetzt Sonnenblumenöl, ihr könnt auch jedes andere neutrale Öl nehmen.
Einmal rein. Da hab' ich die Zwiebeln schon fein geschnippelt, die gebe ich auch mit dazu
und meine Knoblauchzehen werde ich pressen.
So, Zwiebeln und Knoblauch durften jetzt 1min lang schön dünsten. Dazu kommt noch Kurkuma,
das hab' ich mit meinem Wiegemesser klein gemacht weil ihr sonst ganz gelbe Finger habt und das sehr schwer rausgeht.
So, das gebe ich noch mit dazu, dünste das noch eine gute ½min mit an,
und dann gebe ich schon mein Fleisch dazu. Ich nehme heute Hähnchenbrustfilet, hab' das auch schon in mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten
und das salze ich erst später. Viele salzen das vorher, ich salze es in dem Fall erst später.
Und das Hähnchen wird auch nur von jeder Seite ganz kurz angebraten,
grad nur so 1min. Und jetzt fange ich auch schon an und geb' die cremigen Zutaten dazu.
Hier habe ich einmal Frischkäse - neutral, also ohne Kräuter oder sonst irgendwas - das gebe ich mit dazu.
Und ein bisschen Sahne. In dieses Rezept kommt wirklich nur ein bisschen Sahne, das sind grade mal 100ml.
Aber wie gesagt: Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen auch unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Und dann würze ich das mit Salz, Pfeffer und Paprikapulver.
So, jetzt habe ich das Ganze geschlossen 10min lang köcheln lassen
weil das Hähnchen braucht wirklich nicht lange  dadurch, dass es schon - Huch, seht ihr mich noch?
(H: Ja!)
Dadurch, dass es schon klein geschnitten wurde
braucht's eben nicht so lange, bei mir so ungefähr 12min.
Nach 10min auf mittlerer Stufe gebe ich jetzt kleine Mozzarella-Kügelchen da rein
und lasse sie in der Resthitze - Moment, den Herd schalte ich aus - lasse sie in der Resthitze jetzt nochmal schmelzen.
Und dann wär's eigentlich so weit! Also das war's, ging jetzt auch richtig schnell!
Das war's schon! Und was ich euch noch sagen wollte als Tipp falls euch das jetzt zu flüssig ist - ich zeig's jetzt mal hier -
Falls euch das jetzt zu flüssig ist - ich mag das weil ich tränke meinen Reis gleich damit! -
dann könnt ihr das auch noch andicken mit ein bisschen Mehl und Wasser, das ist ja gar kein Problem.
Ich geb' da ganz zum Schluss noch ein bisschen Petersilie drauf und ihr könnt eigentlich tun und lassen was ihr möchtet!
Da passen jetzt noch z.B. Paprika, Brokkoli, Mais, Möhren..alles, was ihr möchtet. Gebt alles rein!
Achtet nur auf die Garzeit. Das Gemüse, das am längsten garen muss, kommt natürlich als allererstes rein.
Und umgekehrt das, was nur ganz kurz braucht, das kommt dann ganz zum Schluss rein. Habe ich erwähnt, dass ich Erbsen reingetan hab?
(H: Ich weiß es nicht!)
Ich weiß es auch nicht aber es war auch ein sehr spontanes Video!
Ich hab gesagt: "Hamza, ich koch jetzt ne richtig schöne Schlemmerpfanne!"
und er meinte: "Das hört sich gut an, sollen wir das nicht abfilmen?" Und deswegen stehen wir jetzt hier!
Also ich hoffe, dass euch das Rezept gefällt!
(H: Aber im Endeffekt habe ich euch das Rezept jetzt gezeigt!)
Eigentlich..
ja, eigentlich hast du's gezeigt im Prinzip!
(H: *lacht*)
Also ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachkochen!
Guten Hunger! Hinterlasst mir einen Kommentar, wie's euch geschmeckt hat
Und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal, Däumchen nach oben nicht vergessen!
Tschüss!